there he is bad brad keller now the era
he's continuing to move it on the
downswing you see his strikeouts to
walks you know a lot of walks this year
donaldson gets a base hit to right field
they gave him a little room to work with
over there and he put it on the ground
for a single
it's to left field down for a hit
donaldson to second base so first and
second one down
and hits that one sharply but right at
carlos santana so keller works out of
the jam only needs 16 pitches
shoemaker his fastball he has to throw
it enough to keep hitters off of his
slider and his split changes he throws
the slider has been very effective for
him
hit sharply past the no at first and
whit has himself a base hit
and now a walk to santana and the royals
have the first two on now it's andrew
benintendi
centerfield celestino broke in now going
back and that ball's off the top of the
wall
merrifield will score they're going to
hold santana at third the royals take a
one-nothing lead and ben and tendy
missed a home run by about two feet
sixth double it was a power double look
at the split finger see it up heck it
wasn't even up it was knee high but
middle of the plate and the sound of the
of the the contact was pure it was a
clean sound you could tell it was hit a
long way you hit a ball 410 feet and get
a double out of it that's a tough tough
chance there here comes trouble in
salvador perez
to right center field this will score
two
income santana in comes ben and tendy
three-nothing royals the royals continue
to punish shoemaker with
all of his pitches
i mean it's incredible this is a
wonderful hit here by salvi i can't
believe they they gave in to him and
threw him a pitch that he could hit
catcher's interference again
how about that yeah he's way too close
you know he's he's figuring that out too
right here a great opportunity for
michael a
taylor there's a base hit to left field
in comes salvador perez right behind him
hunter dozier the throw to the plate is
cut off and the royals take a
five-nothing lead
and that's just
outstanding hitting shoemaker making a
mistake with his curveball he hung it
and a hitter can see that a mile away
michael a taylor stayed on top of it and
was able to
find that hole in the left side great
stroke clutch hit
make him four for seven with him loaded
royals sending their ninth man to the
play to nikki lopez
back up the middle and that will leap
into center field well the royals are
not only good but they are fortunate
right now
because that looked like it might be
fielded for a double play
and it took a wicked bounce and hopped
over the shortstop's head into center
field whitmerfield started the hit
parade with a single to right
fielder the high drive to left
that's back at the fence and that's a
gunner home run with merrifield and the
royals are blowing out minnesota in this
first inning
went merrifield putting an exclamation
point on this inning and
giving
shoemaker
a parting gift
that was witt's first home run since may
3rd when he took savali of cleveland
deep some 102 at bats ago the royals
lead it nine nothing and the 2-2 swing
at a miss and dozier strikes out and
this horrific inning is finally over the
royals score in nine it'll be calvin
gutierrez to lead off the second
gutierrez slaps a base hit into left
field so he has joined the hit parade
and the royals have their
lead off man on to start the second
solaire whistles that one by astadillo
racing to third is gutierrez and solaire
he now has a base hit and the royals
threatening to
add some more here in the second inning
michael taylor
to right field that's a beautiful piece
of hitting
in comes gutierrez it's ten nothing
royals we'll move on to the number two
hitter now carlos santana
hit sharply into right field that will
score at least two
12-nothing k.c
[Applause]
to the right side gordon goes to second
and they won't get ben and tendy
and checking in from third is nikki
lopez to make it 13-0 kiriloff singled
his first time up and he has donaldson
at first and polanco at third base and
the 2-1 pitch ground ball left side this
is backhanded by the third baseman's
second for one the return is going to be
not in time
as the run scores polanco was in
donaldson out at second base kiriloff's
save
on the fielder's choice rbi twins are on
the board 13-1
here's polanco to lead off the fifth
with the ball driven to right center
field and deep and polanco
banks one off the ad by the fountains
and polancos hit his sixth home run of
the year here leading off the fifth
inning
second hit of the ball game and
no success off keller coming in
and all of a sudden he's got a couple of
hits
will take over and he was recalled
yesterday to mark his second step with
the big league club this year
lopez
oh that's a nice play from deep short to
get that force to win
better believe that he's a confident
fielder right now you can tell
he's he's there's a second really good
play he made i mean watch the watch what
he gets on it he's able to get a lot on
that throw and got him by plenty
lopez fires to first and gets his man
another fine play by nikki lopez and he
is putting on a defensive clinic today
this one here where the guy can run the
ball bounces off the plate it's like a
bouncing the super ball nicki with some
quickness there got rid of it with some
petrol on it here's the 2-2
swinging in the miss he struck him out
so bolanos gave up a couple of hits he
had some really good defense behind him
now dice in the batter
dyson knocks one up the middle
backhanded by the second baseman his
throat not in time and the royals score
their 14th run on an infield hit
by giraffe lead off walk and now suno
hoping to end an old for 24.
3-1 pitch a drive to right center field
deep in the alley that ball travels near
the wall and gone miguel ceno with a
two-run homer here at the eighth inning
and it's now 14-4 to those 18th home run
lifetime against the royals 11th at
kauffman stadium gordon tonight with a
couple of singles he's two out of three
gordon
sending the centerfielder tucker back
and that ball is gone
nick gordon
with his dad watching
a three-hit night and his first big
league home run well that's got to feel
good
get that one out of the way
urban santana comes out of the bullpen
to try and get those final three outs
[Music]
ball hit to left back goes dyson still
going back he leaps
and makes a spectacular catch
gerard dyson wow to end it
what a play this was great timing
bounced off the wall
oh look at him look once where he was
that'll be on the highlight reel
the royals really playing well right now
they've won five straight ball games and
they are 13 and six since that nasty 11
game losing streak